help us change the culture by buying our
latest single from timcast records only
ever wanted by clicking the link in the
description below
I want to jump to this next story from
timcast.com Senator Lindsey Graham says
there will be riots in the streets if
Trump is indicted Senator Lindsey Graham
was has warned there'll be rides in the
street if Trump is indicted the
Republican South Carolina Senator made
the remarks during an appearance on Fox
news's Sunday night in America over the
weekend echoing Trump's recent claim
that America is now a lawless country
Graham said there is no law when it
comes to taking down the former
president
quote most Republicans including what do
you say including me as a typo in there
timcast.com believe when it comes to
Trump there is no law it's all about
getting him and I'll say this if there
is a prosecution of Donald Trump from
his handling classified information and
after the Clinton debacle there will be
riots in the streets
I completely disagree
I I 100 disagree the right doesn't Riot
no we would never I mean there's been a
few instances I mean January 6 for
instance was pretty bad but it's like
they just don't uh I I remember as a
Trump Tower are there people protesting
it and there was a guy who was you know
was asking questions about what's going
on and they said he was and then he was
like well I'm a trump supporter but you
know I don't know and then I was like
why don't you guys come out and like
voice your support oh no no I I could I
couldn't do that I couldn't do that well
there you go the end result of refusing
to speak your mind is being obliterated
from culture and from mainstream Society
the your inability to stand up and
support the things you like or
speak out in support of
anything related to your values will be
the end of your values yeah well they
know this right like I mean that I think
that was a big part in why Joe Biden won
is that people didn't want riots again I
heard that from many of my friends many
of my liberal friends they were like
yeah I actually don't agree with what a
lot of Joe says I actually like Trump's
fiscal policy or I like Trump for
whatever reason but I don't want riots I
don't want my city to burn down you know
they lived in Chicago or they lived in
Florida they lived in these different
cities around the country people just
didn't want the riots they were fed up
with it and I think the the media
knowing this the government of people
knowing this
is even maybe part in you know why they
why they rated his home or why they take
this this massive action against the
president because they know they'll get
away with it
I'm so disappointed they didn't sit in
the National Guard at night too man I'll
talk about it over and over again when
it comes up but like what a failure of
leadership to allow those riots
absolutely
I'm not a big fan of Lindsey Graham I
don't like his alcoholism I think he's
an alcohol personally I think he's an
alcoholic when I look in his eyes
but uh well okay personal feelings aside
Lindsay I don't know if you're an
alcoholic or if you struggled alcoholics
I'm sorry I hope you can overcome that
but uh you know you say if this happens
there will be riots that's not a form of
incitement but it kind of sounds like
you're telling people to go ride if it
happens so watch your tone you know
secondly he's not wrong about what he's
saying about the the Biden crap
the daily wire recently hired at Disney
executive and people started going
ragging on him for it and I'm just like
the CEO of this company goes to church
on Sunday guys the Disney guy now works
for him why are you why are you ragging
on The Daily wire over this why are
people saying you better explain this
yeah it's called winning it's called
taking over the industry and taking over
the culture that's that's a that's a
problem I think you know Purity tests
it is what it is but the left is so
obedient to their cult they have a major
advantage over the culture War right and
that the cultural right will will bicker
the left will devour each other but the
individualists on the right are more
defined and willing to just say what
they think what's happening is this left
idea this cultism is like a communist
cultism kind of thing and there's so
much of the world as communist in China
and in at least a lot of the Russian
holdover states have communist threads
throughout whether or not they're
overtly Communists so it's for the first
time in human history is bleeding
through the internet into American
culture like we didn't have the internet
before it wasn't so pervasive and
permeable and so we're seeing this
insane
bubble of communist Behavior it's crazy
it's not American it's not normal in the
United States it's very they thought the
FBI was went after this for like 60
years or something 50 years they were
trying to stop the Communist overthrow I
don't know it turns out maybe we're not
communist communist because it's like
it's more than just that like the
Chinese culture the CCP it's not real
communism it's like an evolution a new
form of technocratic you know oversight
that's not just cut but there are
communist aspects to it I think I think
the the solution to a lot of this stuff
is ignore the tribes I think the left is
the cultier side but the right has their
issues sure but it's the exception not
the rule I think the issue is just
compete in the space
fund and grow and and assert yourself in
these spaces which is what we've been
trying to do it's why we've we're not
launching overtly political stuff so
we're not we're not launching stuff to
try and Pander to Trump supporters or
liberals or whatever we're trying to
make things they'll be entertaining
enough for regular people
well I think you know this is something
that the left gets really right and
they're really good at is they have
their allies and they clearly Define
their enemies and they let you know
people in the Democratic party they'll
slip up they'll make a mistake but they
won't banish them right and the right
will keeps thinking that they're going
to win brownie points for taking the
high road right the staffer says
something that's a little bit uncouth
and then they banish them they say well
we're not racist well we're not sexist
it's like they're already calling you
that you're not going to win brownie
points for taking the high road and
again this is what the left does really
well it's what I said earlier that's
their superpower their cult mentality is
their superpower is they can mess up
they can do actually racist things like
Katie Hub but do they bring that up do
they call it her racism no because they
know that Katie Hobbs is her or their
Ally they will they will help her to get
through that and they they don't care
because they have their allies and they
have their enemies and the right needs
to get this through their heads or
they're going to continue losing yeah
it's not a time for people to sit still
and just take whatever you the high road
to turn the other cheek to look the
other way is not the time to do this
time to create stuff to create
phenomenal addictive art that is so good
we're working on a video game you know I
don't know it's really hard work uh
Andrew our game game design has done an
incredible job it's real fun Sheamus is
doing the animations and stuff and uh
this is not I guess the I I we haven't
released a lot of information about the
game we've shown like clips of it and
stuff
man it's uh it's it's it's relatively
political but it's not the game itself
it's just a video game we're going to be
able to play as U10 with little uh
customizable actual different color
beanies no but we like I think Ian's
gonna be in it actually got paid 99
cents to get the skin no I don't know
about DLC actually I think I think
you're gonna end up being like a special
character or something
also does really well they're they're
the creatives they're making movies
they're making the art but they're
losing it and now is the opportunity
that's why it's like well thanks to
people like you right putting out your
your songs and you know driving traffic
and like you said rejecting the
mainstream culture rejecting the the
mainstream media and this it is great it
has been one of the most stressful
things ever doing all this work to
launch music more so than like
I've been playing music since since I
was like seven but I didn't expect any
of this stuff to start happening like a
million views I was just like uh okay
like we left the show on Friday I'm like
oh you're number one in alt rock on
iTunes and I was like holy crap and then
the these are the attacks we started
getting have been unrelenting you know
I'm gonna stop using the term attack
when it comes to verbal crap
why won't you call it an attack because
it's it's softening the term attack and
then making Street violence less uh
threatening I don't think so look the
goal is to inflict it then it's
harassment I guess if the goal is to
inflict emotional harm but what I see
here is
you know we we launched pop culture
crisis it's it's growing really really
well for a show that's only you know
like half a year old 40 000 Subs getting
thousands of of views in their in their
episodes uh they they Brett and Mary are
just doing an amazing job and it's
talking about pop culture it's not
political and that's the point it's like
we want to just meet people where they
are and produce content for them and
then create a sphere of influence
no hate no one came after us over this
test from the inverted world we got
actually some you know positive it's
true crime but then we put out a song
that just took off like crazy and all of
a sudden we have all of these left
pundits just attacking us relentlessly
and I think it's because this is
this is the move to make the left took
the Arts over they used the Arts to
influence children they want the kids to
grow up to be like them
controlling movies controlling
superheroes controlling TV shows you
can't turn on a show without getting
some garbage message now and that's what
they're trying to instill in your kids
if they can't get them in the schools
they're gonna get them on the TVs and
then parents who don't know about her
put their iPad in front of their kids
and the kids now just listening to all
the stuff so what happens when you get a
daily wire producing movies daily wire
bought hyperions which was just a
Hollywood movie and they got really
angry there was that Viral thread this
is exactly the point where they were
like I watched this movie and then I
realized it was a daily wire movie and I
was like oh no what was I promoting and
I deleted it remember that what were
they shouting out
I forget but I remember this lady wrote
this ridiculous article about how she uh
actually enjoyed a daily wire movie and
she was really regretful because she had
tweeted Ron had fight run fight was that
is that what it's called that's the
movie so they tweeted that they watched
run hide fight and it was really good
and they told people to watch it and
then people were like that's the daily
wire they went oh no oh I'm so sorry Ben
Shapiro walked into our podcast
conference I tell you this they're not
scared of you doing a show and being
like politics politics because they know
how to control you they know how to say
you're a fascist and then scare people
away from talking to you but when you
make a movie that's really good that
they like oh no now you're gonna start
influencing people now you're gonna
start winning friends and influencing
people and that's how they lose the
culture War it's remarkable to me that
the right is so resistant in many ways
not everybody to making culture in order
to win a culture War Andrew Breitbart
said this what was what was this now
like 14 years ago that that politics is
Downstream from culture every person on
the right should be focused on Art
politics of course you know Tom McDonald
is probably one of the greatest
musicians of Our Generation because he's
he's hitting powerful messages he's he's
speaking to tens of millions of people
and boy are they pissed about it this is
what really grinds their gears and
freaks them out this is what this is
what wins not writing when you're
violent they know how to control you
they know that normal people get scared
of the violence they can show that on TV
screens all year and blame Donald Trump
for it but you know they can't do
anything about a song called fjb hitting
number one a song called fake woke
hitting number one the daily wire
putting out eight political movies that
people enjoy that is freaking them out
these people are pathetic dude like
they're literally pathetic I mean I
think they think that they're
strong-minded I think they think that
they have some serious rooted values but
in reality it's like you you are so
weak-minded that you have no idea I mean
the Bible makes it clear that you know
the fear of man is a snare what that
means is as you live your life afraid of
the opinions of people of what people
think about you or what people are
saying about you oh the mob over there
is going to think I look like this if I
listen to Tim Poole I actually like this
song I'm not actually gonna stop
listening to Tim Poole because I found
out that he's an ALT right whatever I'm
just gonna do it in secret like imagine
being so pathetic so pathetic that you
can't be yourself you can't be yourself
out in the open you can actually like
what you actually like because it's so
politically polarized imagine being so
pathetic that you cannot stand your
ground and just be yourself
you're an NPC you're a robot you're
controlled you're controlled by the mob
you don't have an opinion for yourself
you're told what to believe you're told
what to believe by pressure and through
fear you may not even really believe it
you may not even really believe it but
you just know that oh someone on Tick
Tock believed it and they got canceled I
don't ever want to be that okay people
like that are pathetic and they're
losers well this is the thing too like
what we're saying about Nickelback it's
like dude you can rag on Nickelback all
day and all day and night fine whatever
but like to deny objectively they scored
a four-week streak at the number one
spot like that means people like that
stuff you don't have to like it that's
fine but to act like they they're
they're not objectively successful it's
just weird cult-like Behavior it is a
form of losing too like you called
people losers but it's like they lose
their opportunity to be themselves which
is the most elevating piece of freeing
experience on Earth if you have a chance
as a human to speak openly about what
you believe and yeah these I mean these
people do need to be prayed for they are
and PCS what you were saying is exactly
right Drew but that Revelation is so
powerful because I think you know it's
like if they're already calling me
racist for just my beliefs that aren't
controversial if they're already calling
me sexist
then then I'm just gonna go pedal to the
metal and Go full throttle and take it
back in any way I can
um because they're and like you said
they're NPCs they're they're controlled
by fear and when you break that
simulation
amazing things so you give people
bravery yeah absolutely
absolutely yeah these people are
destroying everything I mean like I mean
you look at have you seen watch have you
watched Eagle yep right it's it's just
this attack on men right it needs to be
combated with men coming out and just
attacking it as a response right because
when when you let this agenda come out
and everyone gets demasculized everyone
gets feminized and and oh everything's
toxic because you're masculine no be
more masculine come out and be
aggressive yes yes but look at Eric July
look at Ripa verse yeah how much did he
make I think it was like over three
million three million the Ripa verse the
rip averse yeah and what what PayPal
froze his money this is the scariest
thing to the cult successful culture
building they they lose their minds over
it they have to reject it they have to
attack it and what do you how do they
they can't stop it they can't and and
that's I think you know when when
She-Hulk comes out and it's and it's
it's hilariously bad garbage or whatever
it's like the lowest rate rated show
that Marvel's done yet it's just it's
cringy I give it like a c minus I I
watch it there's some funny bits in it
but it is not it is what it is and if
people like it I'm fine with them liking
it Miss Marvel was way worse in my
opinion that was like a Magic School Bus
show a PSA on partition in Pakistan or
whatever if you don't like it let me ask
you something when you don't like here
we go here we go Drew uh name a song you
don't like
um
Friday Friday Rebecca Black okay that
song was from 12 Years 12 years ago I
think is there a song from this week
that you don't like that's like in the
news
I don't even I don't know what's out
right now exactly because you don't
focus on things you don't like you focus
on the things you do like so for these
people to come out and start attacking
and criticizing the daily wire the stuff
we're doing or or you know anybody else
that's when you know you're having an
impact
exactly they the real threat it's not
that people on in cultists can't stop
the the art the phenomenal art that's
appearing it's that they don't want to
that's the real threat in their minds
it's like a cognitive this is like I
like this I don't want to stop this I
was told that I'm not I'm supposed to
fear it but it's good and I feel better
and that's like this coming to terms
with yourself or your a you know that's
it's a it's a phenomenal it's a great
thing to win I I think the response to
She-Hulk should be what Eric July is
doing make like daily wires should be
working on adaptations of of his stuff
they should be like okay how do we turn
this into a big show because clearly the
audience wants it there's a market
opportunity and that's how you win a
culture War by making culture now I'm so
I mean look dude hearing that dude made
over three million dollars
oh it's a bright it's a breath of fresh
air the more the more people are start
start working on this stuff the more
people start producing and developing
culture that's look the elections are
great but but politics is Downstream
from culture you get a law in the books
that your culture is unwilling to
enforce the laws meaningless even John
Roberts didn't want to overturn Roe v
Wade because of where the culture was at
but then you end up with you know these
three these several other justices for
the justices and then it becomes well
you got no choice now that's Donald
Trump getting them in but look at what
happens when you don't have the culture
they demonize Trump and they go after
them relentlessly you you need if every
celebrity was was was more like we have
to support America otherwise I'll we'll
lose our jobs this country would be
doing well instead they're like you have
to hate America otherwise we lose our
jobs that is an inverse economic
incentive that is destroying this
country well like that's the dangerous
thing about censorship is it if you
censor something enough it's not going
to solve any problems it's just going to
make that thing come back with a
Vengeance it's going to swing back even
harder and I think that was you know
Trump's whole ethos right that they were
just suppressing the right to spread and
then he came back with this with this
you know he came back intensely and I
think it's the same thing with
masculinity if you suppress masculinity
enough it's going to come back even
harder you know you see that with Andrew
Tate and regardless of all the things he
says it's like they're censoring
masculinity they're they're you know I'm
an eagle scout they kicked uh you know
they started lending women into to the
Boy Scouts and it's like masculinity
came back even harder and even more
toxic or whatever you want to call it so
I think this this censorship doesn't
solve anything in the long term
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there